so that thing  that's a whisper too huh looks a lot  more like an arbiter of faith than the  others  we can beat them  i think it's coming this way  what have you done  let's make it a night to remember  now let the hunch begin  cloud lend me your strength  let us defy destiny together  don't deny me embrace me  i hate to be the bearer of bad news but  just hit me with it  i'm gonna drop plate number seven  they're gonna do what  i did bring these bhutai's famous to  chow beans  eat up and here you go you look about  ready to die of boredom  want to play fort condor or condor  [Music]  at long last wutai's finest dane to join  us  i was scarlett director of advanced  weaponry it was one of her machines that  killed melfi  allow me to present the latest  innovation in  shinra battle armor this will be a  memory to cherish for the rest of your  lives  all 30 seconds of them  how dare you how dare you stand in my  way  let the games begin  this is just wrong  [Music]  [Music]  playstation